Thank You Nick now and i call scott
barrett and after Scott Jeffrey Sachs
well thank you very much i feel pretty
intimidated partly because I'm so far
down the list of speakers that you've
already heard so much I don't know if I
could add much that's new and by the way
these speakers are real modelers and i'm
not i make zum Berg of this information
rather than a producer so my views may
be a little different I'm also
intimidated because I don't have
powerpoint so you may wonder whether I
have anything to say and finally I'm
intimidated because I realized that I'm
the only person between yourself and
professor Sachs but i'll try to say
something anyway ernesto zedillo when he
opened the session this morning said
that the people at Davos had agreed in a
poll that climate change was the world's
greatest problem and ernesto said that
he wasn't sure if it was it was sure
that he did not agree with that well
when I was visiting at the Yale Center
last year I was working on lots of
global problems of which climate was one
I'm also not sure it's well I am Not
sure that climate is the the biggest but
what I am absolutely sure of is that
it's the most complicated I've worked on
this not as long as some people here but
a long time and it's an incredibly
complicated problem and the thing about
the stern report that really struck me
was that it had to reduce something that
was incredibly complicated to a very
simple recommendation and a very
unambiguous recommendation now since the
report came out Nick and his team have
produced this PostScript and I think
that addresses my initial
reaction to a large extent to the report
but I still think that there is a great
service that's being provided by the
certain review and that is to draw
attention to the ethics of this problem
and also I think there may be an
inconsistency within the review itself
about how thix how ethics are treated
and my guess is that Nick may even agree
with me about this but we'll see the
choice we have here is really about
people taking actions now that will have
consequences a long time into the future
in the stern review the real damages
start to appear after 2050 and then they
start to get they mount 2,100 2,200 this
is everyone understands that this is the
nature of this problem so when we speak
about taking action now you're talking
about taking in a way taking something
away from the current generation and
giving it to the future generation so
you're thinking about well beings in
different periods of time and that's why
this is such a profound ethical issue
now there are there are two ways as
we've heard before about how you treat
well-being in these different places and
one is this Delta this pureed a time
preference and why should we treat
people differently just because they
exist in the future well actually nick
says that we should treat them a little
differently simply because there's a
small probability that they may not
exist and he cites as examples of this
the possibility of the earth being
slammed by an asteroid and of a terrible
global pandemic well actually while I
was at the Yale Center I was working on
these two problems and pleased to tell
you that actually we can we can do
things to address these problems too so
maybe maybe that period of time
preference could even be a little
smaller the the other the other thing
that's going on here is that between now
and the future more is going to change
than just the climate and the thing that
changes in the model that Nick uses is /
kappa
consumption and it rises quite
dramatically over time and the reason it
rises so much is the effect of compound
growth in fact if I've understood things
correct the future even with climate
change is better off than the present in
terms of per capita consumption so what
he's asking is that the current
generation make sacrifices for the
future when the future is going to have
a higher per capita consumption level
and you can see why this is an important
issue for ethics because it really
raises this issue about the concern that
we should have for equity now when you
as everyone has said before the the
parameter that represents a concern for
equity is this ADA parameter and Nick
chooses a number value that is
relatively low I I think by the way that
the choices of these parameters the the
period time preference and the aid our
best thought of as social choices and
not so much choices for me or for anyone
else to make in particular there are
number of ways in which you could think
about this ADA in any event it seems
relatively low and the reason as we've
heard before that the current generation
should make sacrifices for the future is
because even though the future is much
better off than we are we don't care so
much about equity if you cared more
about equity you'd want to have the
current generation which is poor
sacrifice less now this is only part of
the story though because if you read the
text very carefully it's clear that nyx
turn is very concerned about equity in
fact what he basically is saying that we
the the we should take steps now he he's
saying that the rich countries today
should take steps now to reduce the
extent of climate change particularly as
it affects poor countries in the future
okay so on the one hand you have a
current relatively poor generation
making sacrifices for relatively Richard
generation in the future
and the other hand and the text you have
today's richer countries making
sacrifices for today's poorer countries
in the future okay so this seems to be a
slight inconsistency and I think the
inconsistency arises because the stern
review is kind of straight jacketed by
the model and the model allows if I've
understood things correctly as nick has
used it interactions between rich and
poor societies only through emissions so
if you had a concern about equity the
only way you could do it if I've
understood things correctly is you
reduce emissions now to help the poor
countries in the future there's no other
way you could do it now what I want to
suggest is that there are other ways
that we could do it one of the ones gave
you one example one of the effects of
climate change that people are concerned
about quite Riley is on malaria and on
the spread of malaria now the best paper
i've seen on this suggests that by
around 2100 the prevalence of malaria
might rise about 5% okay and basically
that's happening because malaria the the
the ecosystems are tolerating the vector
higher up the hillsides it's basically
on altitude that that malaria would
spread so if we reduce emissions we
would reduce the increase in malaria a
century and more ahead but there's
another way to think about this and that
is that if we did something like
developed a malaria vaccine and I'm
thinking about this more as a metaphor
that has something to be taken entirely
literally but you could through a
malaria vaccine you could reduce malaria
across the board and you could do it
much sooner and my point is that if
you're going to reduce sorry if you're
going to increase the ADA because you're
concerned with equity and that means
that the social cost of carbon comes
down and therefore you do less abatement
now you also have to recognize that
concern about equity to be to have its
effects somewhere
else okay you can't have it you can't
just sort of narrow it one way and leave
everything else the same and I think the
case about equity then is not only
partially about reducing abatement for
the future it's also about doing more
than just reducing emissions is
providing for adaptation adaptation we
normally think of as being well the Seas
rise let's build higher dykes but
actually I think a better way to think
about apt adaptation is making
particularly the poorer countries less
vulnerable to climate change for more
resilient and investments in
technologies like malaria vaccines would
do that now I think Nick is very aware
of this and he's of course very
concerned about development and in his
post grip he refers to this problem of
development assistance and he says that
he's basically relying on pledges that
the richer countries have made to
developing countries being realized in
the future and I have five comments to
make about that first is that I hope
he's right I hope it is forthcoming the
second is that pledges aren't always
fulfilled the third is that the issue is
less money than what is actually
achieved by the money of course the
fourth is though and this is important
that adaptation and mitigation they are
interrelated and so there really should
be co determined if countries are going
to get away with doing less mitigation
for example then that really means that
needs to be more adaptation and we know
that the poorer countries are relatively
the most vulnerable and will need
assistance so those two things I think
should be coupled and finally this is
quite important and it was brought out
by lovely pop at that judges bhagwati
wrote the there is an obligation and
nick has said this before two for the
richer countries to help the poorer
countries so we think about development
assistance in a way that's driven a lot
by compassion and compassion
unfortunately is rather in short supply
but here the motivation be a little
different it would be a recognition of
an obligation a responsibility to help
countries that would be harmed by the
actions of the industrialized countries
in in the past now the real big question
I think is not whether we act now or not
I think everyone agrees we should act
now it's much more about what can we do
and I'm just going to suggest very
briefly that what we need to think about
are five different things and first is I
agree with Nick that you want countries
to take action now and probably the way
to think about it is they'll do it on
their own and that they'll be looking
over each other's shoulders and I would
actually rather they did this through
international agreements simply because
you create a kind of normative standard
for for what countries ought to do about
this problem but what I think you can't
do is rely on strong-armed enforcement
at the international level particularly
for this problem I think that'd be very
difficult so I think he's right that you
probably want to rely more on domestic
enforcement I think internationally
naming and shaming but I think the idea
of having strong enforcement is probably
going to be difficult that means that
this approach can only get us up so high
okay and I think everyone agrees that we
want to do more than just going up a bit
particularly in the longer run so that's
why more things need to be done so the
second thing that is really quite
important is that we invest
substantially in R&D you actually the
way to think about this is if you're
going to have a material effect on the
climate you basically have to transform
energy technology worldwide okay this is
something we've never done before this
is unprecedented and this is a huge
challenge for us but the technologies
that we're going to need don't really
exist so they need to be we need basic
research in this to to discover and to
develop these technologies then this is
the third thing we need a mechanism to
defuse these technologies worldwide
because if you have the ideas you know
how to do it and it's not distributed it
won't do any good so those two things
also are linked the third thing is we
need to do adaptation and as I suggested
I think adaptation needs to be think
thought of much more broadly than just
building dikes I think it's a lot more
than that and adaptation we should be
doing now for that reason we should be
making poor countries especially more
the R&D we should do now short term
mitigation we should do now now the last
thing I think we should think about is
probably the wrong thing to suggest at
the very end of a talk because it's an
awkward in many ways bizarre idea it's
called geoengineering and the idea here
is that you could deliberately alter the
climate now I know this is kind of scary
your first hear it it sounds bizarre but
actually the technology has been
examined by a number of people it looks
like this it's feasible and it has a
kind of a mixed a mixed kind of effect
on the one hand it's the only way in
which you could possibly stop abrupt and
catastrophic change from happening after
you started to see it beginning and
that's a good thing about it however
your then undertaking another kind of
experiment and we don't know what the
full consequences of that would be one
of the issues and it would not address
ocean acidification that was mentioned
before but one of the problems with
geoengineering is that the economics are
in a way so attractive that a more
fundamental problem arises for
governance who's to decide when and
under what conditions geoengineering
ought to be used this which you may not
have heard much about i think is an
issue in a technology on the horizon and
what we really need is a governance
structure that will prepare us for that
as well thank you very much
just a couple points I think clearly
Nick's report has had a huge political
effect and it's proven again the
endogeneity of davos polling by the way
which shifts from world's most important
topic systematically year by year
depending on what the most interesting
headline was the month before and the
stern review was the most interesting
headline the month before and the Davos
community has duly gotten in line which
is all to the good except it won't last
two years in a row so you better get the
results you need this year I'm wondering
how much disagreement there really is in
the rhetoric on the panel that's my my
main question and it's a little bit hard
to know because most of the discussion
is how fast should we do what we need to
do and is Nick calling for a crash
course in doing something while the rest
of us are calling for something more
gradual or mainstream says do it
gradually and mixing do it in a crash
course I certainly didn't feel when I
read the report that that's really what
it was about I read mix call to action
as let's get started now understanding
that this will take decades now maybe I
have not interpreted correctly the
report if it didn't say that that's what
it should have said but my view is that
it did say that and there are incredibly
powerful reasons for putting it that way
and that is that we're talking about
changing the core infrastructure of the
world economy and it will take several
decades to do to do it faster than that
really would impose marginal costs which
would be extraordinarily hard to justify
on the scientific evidence because the
scientific evidence suggests at least as
we know it now that if we act with
all deliberate speed right now planning
by mid-century to really have completed
a huge change over we will have been
able to keep the dangerous emissions
below catastrophic level and since Nick
talks about stabilizing at 450 to 550
and that's possible on a scenario of all
deliberate speed taking to account the
time horizons of demonstration and
investment in long-lived infrastructure
that's what I took the report to be
what's also true is if you wait another
20 years then the window closes on
certain concentration levels and you
can't any longer at all deliberate speed
reach 450 to 550 level now there is one
major confusion which I think should
have been straightened out in the report
and still should be straightened out
will be straighten out inevitably in the
discussions Nick's talking about 450 to
550 parts per million carbon equivalent
meaning adding up all of the greenhouse
gases there's a little a at the bottom
all the rest of us are talking about
parts per million of carbon and this is
a big difference actually and so it's
not clear what really is going on here
because the study is overwhelmingly
about carbon and only very little about
the movements of the other radiative
force and gases I'm quite happy with the
450 to 550 ppm carbon target I'm not
sure I don't have the same Bayesian
confidence in my views about a 450 to
550 ppm carbon equivalent level and I'd
like to know a little bit more about
that the scientists at the Earth
Institute argue strongly for keeping
these separate in terms of public
discussion and understanding and not
simply adding the radiative forcings and
for good economic reasons we can
understand why not to lump them together
as well for many
reasons they need different prices they
have different systems they have
different residence times in the
atmosphere and it is a little bit of a
mess I think to have a target that is
that is adding up six or more greenhouse
gases this way but if we could then
stipulate i'm going to stipulate from
now on I'm talking about 450 to 550
parts per million carbon rather than
carbon equivalent it would take really a
it would take a profoundly dislocating
set of actions to achieve that before to
aim to stabilize below such levels for
example and on the other hand if we
start now it would be possible to
stabilize in that range without severe
dislocation one thing that almost none
of the models formally takes into
account is the true putty clay nature of
almost everything we we live with our
fleet of automobiles turns over in 20
years our power plants turnover in 40 to
50 years or longer our residential
structures 50 years to a hundred years
and similarly with our commercial
structures in general everything can be
retrofit but it's a heck of a lot more
expensive to retrofit than it is to
invest in the prospective phase for
decarbonizing energy or reducing
emissions in other ways and so the low
marginal cost pathway is one that takes
the easy wins of course where you can
find them and there's a lot of waste in
the system but then invests as you roll
off old capital and roll on new capital
some of it's literally the rolling stock
of our automobile fleet most importantly
it's the stock of our power plants if we
were to decommission live existing
well-functioning coal plants right now
and build holy
new power plants that'd be really
expensive actually it would be a huge
change if we took a view instead that as
power plants are mothballed or new ones
are built that they satisfy the
constraints of being carbon effective or
carbon efficient then we'll be able to
manage the transformation at a much much
lower marginal cost so I think any
serious scenario takes into account a
path that's going to last 30 40 50 years
and I took the message from the stern
review that if we're going to take these
limits seriously which we should we've
got to get started now because every new
power plant that's being built and their
gigawatts of power plants that are being
built right now with old-fashioned coal
thermal fired plants all through China
Indian lot of the rest of the world
we're going to lock ourselves into a
time path which will be devastating but
if we get started now so that as the
capital is reinvested its invested in
efficient ways the marginal cost of that
transformation will be quite low now my
view is it's going to be a lot lower
than in bill nor houses model which I
take to be the the state of the art work
horse model of the profession and I'm a
lot more optimistic about this and I'll
try to try to explain why in fact
whenever I disagree with Bill nordhaus I
worry in intensely about why that might
be because he's about the most
reasonable person I know and so I spend
a lot of time in the last few months as
he knows sending lots of emails to try
to understand the assumptions underneath
the dice model and my view is that when
the dice model which is a good standard
simple workhorse model but you got to
still put in parameters to have it come
out with sensible answers when you do
that with what I think are better
parameters than the ones that bill uses
this debate turns out in my opinion not
to be very much about the time discount
rate at all it just turns out to be
about the parameters that one's assuming
about mainly the costs of adjustment
and several other basic features about
the world economy not profound features
but just basic assumptions that are
being made now I may have everything
wrong that I'm about to say but I'm
going to do my best on this and then we
can I apologize in advance what I do
ever wrong but the big Bill's basic
point in comparison say with the what I
would adopt is let's get started now get
started seriously and reach 2050 with
the chance of ending up the century at
500 or 550 ppm and not going above that
Bill's model says no we should do this
over two centuries and we can breach 550
maybe we'll go to 600 or 700 and that's
the right thing to do eventually we will
stabilize but we don't have to do it
within a century and we don't have to do
it at the limits that Nick is talking
about so I take Nick to be saying let's
get on with it so that by 2050 were
still within maybe at 450 ppm and that
gives us a chance that by 2100 we're
still at 500 to 550 ppm and Bill's
models saying no we can go above that be
more gradual maybe we'll do twenty-five
percent abatement control by the end of
the century thirty percent forty percent
but still will breach these limits so I
tried to figure out why that is and one
thing that's interesting about the low
levels of control and I think the sense
of lack of urgency that comes from the
dice model is that the baseline path of
emissions is actually quite a bit lower
than the rest of us assume bills
baseline of no control only reaches 600
10 ppm of carbon by 2100 and I don't
know of another model that's anywhere
close to that in terms of such a low
level but if that's your baseline you
don't feel about control because the
world's already more or less controlling
these things for you and the reason
seems to be if i understand it
for assumptions that I don't like very
much in in the model one is that the
baseline level of economic growth
assumed is only about two percent or so
so the rate of growth of the world
economy is it may be right but it seems
to me not the right base for policy
decision-making because we should
presume that China and India are going
to grow quickly and that that's really
the core of our issue right now is that
there's going to be a lot more carbon
coming from that fact second and again I
apologize if I got it wrong but the
population assumption is just way out of
the norm it's seven point seven billion
by 2050 whereas the medium forecast to
the UN which right or wrong I would take
to be the right medium place to start an
assumption like this is eight point nine
billion then there's an economic
assumption to economic assumptions one
which is better than it was in an
earlier variant is that there's a lot of
automatic decarbonisation that goes on
in the model over the long term it's
less than it used to be used to be a
hundred percent automatic
decarbonisation at no pain in three
centuries now it's substantial
decarbonisation at the end of two
centuries so you end up getting to a
point where you don't really have to
control things because technology at
zero marginal cost controls a lot of it
already but then the fourth point I
think is that the assumed abatement cost
for actually doing something is just
much too high and this is the nub of the
issue actually I think we focus much too
much time in this discussion over the
last ten weeks on the discount rate as
if that's the only thing really going on
where's what seems to me to be going on
even more is the assumption of how much
is it going to cost to clean this stuff
up and in bills model if I get it
there's a parameter for that which has
is time varying but as of mid century
the parameter is such that it implies
that a hundred percent abatement would
cost three-point-nine percent of GNP
and seventy-five percent abatement would
be one point seven percent of GNP I'm
living among technological optimists in
the Earth Institute a world of engineers
who think that that one point seven
percent is roughly five times too high
and I'll explain that in a minute but if
you change that assumption and say that
you can do 75 percent abatement at
something like point six percent of GNP
you get a completely different judgment
on this it has nothing to do with the
time discount it's actually what's the
cost of doing what we need to do and I
think that that's really in the end what
makes the models fly now here's my
attempt to put in an alternative set of
estimates the lowest line is is Bill
Nord houses optimum trajectory on his
baseline parameters and as of 2050
there's point2 abatement meaning that
you abate twenty percent of the
emissions that would normally be there
and by 2100 you obeyed about
thirty-seven percent and 2120 it's a
little bit above forty percent so the
path is like everyone would agree its
upward sloping eventually you would
reach a hundred percent assuming that
that the technological change for free
doesn't do it for you but it's a very
gradual course if you start changing
these assumptions first change the cost
estimate to make it less costly and then
two very basic things let the world
economy grow faster basically let China
and India catch up with a barrow
catching up coefficient rather than
almost no catching up which seems to be
a very slow catching up which seems to
be assumed which puts the world economy
and a five percent per year growth path
right now rather than bills of something
like two percent then you get a much
higher
trajectory and the messages control this
damn stuff it's pouring out of the
smokestacks and so when I add in a
revised cost adjustment plus a faster
growth plus the UN population assumption
I get that by 2060 were at sixty percent
abatement and by 2080 were one hundred
percent abatement in the dice model I
would say to get that we'd have to have
a worldwide agreement now to be able to
make a transformation like that that's
what I would claim to be underpinning a
call to action maybe it doesn't feel
that way but if you're really going to
have a whole world system with a rising
dramatically larger world economy that
has sharply lower emissions than it has
right now you better get started now
because the number of thermal plants the
China and India are going to be building
in the next 20 years would absolutely
make that impossible unless you get
started now what does it mean to get
started now by the way here's I think
where the cost issue comes in again I
live around very optimistic engineers
but I kind of believed them and I think
that that Bob Mendelssohn's analogy was
all wrong on this which is to say we can
only have three percent productivity
growth after all agriculture is so
important is only two percent for
agriculture we've been trying to do this
since 10,000 years ago for carbon
concentration we've worried about it as
engineers about three years there's a
lot of catching up space right now this
is literally a problem that not a single
generation of students went through to
worry about now all of a sudden they
have a playground control that carbon
with all of the technology that you have
in the world we're going to see huge
huge huge opportunities at low cost now
you know my my colleagues are very keen
on a few things one nuclear that's
already proved there are issues about it
but whether we like it or not China and
India and many other places are going to
go nuclear
and that's going to solve a lot of this
problem at quite low cost maybe even at
zero marginal cost compared to a
baseline of thermal but carbon capture
and sequestration is the second very
obvious technology if you look at the
IPCC report that came out on carbon
capture and sequestration they put at
extremely high likelihood there is
enough geological there enough
sedimentary geological sites to safely
sequester centuries of that is
gigatonnes and gigatonnes of carbon
dioxide and their cost estimate is ten
to thirty dollars per ton of co2 roughly
one two three cents a kilowatt hour for
electricity very low marginal cost
technology now we don't know if it works
yet and so if I were choosing the
decision tree right now the first thing
I would do is get some of these
prototype plants up in a heck of a lot
of geologists around the measuring
tracer gases coming out of the deposits
to see whether they're leaking or not
but this to me is the very first step if
we can't do CCS we got a real problem
there's no question about it the next
next best technology is a lot worse than
carbon capture and sequestration but
we're never going to learn that from our
models by the way we're only going to
learn that by putting that into
demonstration projects and seeing
whether this technology which for good
engineering reasons mechanically works
the question is whether geologically
works I think the the mechanics are
quite well understood it's the geology
that needs to be proved now if it turns
out and then there's one other major
area for huge huge improvement of course
and that's automobiles because we
already know that a plug-in hybrid
system can work off the existing
infrastructure and at quite low cost
probably mayor I'd say quite likely zero
or negative social costs because you
trade off higher battery costs and
lower and lower petroleum or carbon
costs and the the net tray that sixty
dollars a barrel of oil is is favorable
at any fairly low interest rate there
may be zero social costs to switching
over if performance and so forth the you
know the if the hedonic aspects of
plug-in hybrids are viewed as are viewed
as acceptable so the point is there are
some major technologies large scale and
this isn't even mentioning you know
cellulosic ethanol and other biofuels
and solar and other things which have
huge huge potential but just the proven
technologies right now if the carbon
capture and sequestration works not the
engineering of it but the the stability
of it if that works we're in a world of
twenty-five or thirty dollars per ton
carbon dioxide on the margin for maybe
up to sixty or seventy percent of the
reduction of the total abatement in the
economy and if CCS works it also allows
one other major thing to be done and
that's to convert existing local site
based fossil fuel users like heat pumps
or I'm sorry like de furnaces and
boilers into electricity users where the
electricity is cleanly produced and the
costs of that kind of conversion say
houses from home heating oil or natural
gas to heat pumps powered by electricity
coming from a clean power plant are
quite favorable as well what's the
bottom line of all of that if you take
an assumption that on the margin or not
on the margin just on the average I
should say that for all of the tons of
co2 that need to be gotten rid of off of
a of a baseline can be disposed of a $25
a ton of co2 turns
out that the costs of doing that for the
world economy is point three of one
percent of GNP and the technologies that
I said just now that i mentioned from
plug-in hybrids to carbon capture
sequestration and nuclear by themselves
are all twenty five to thirty dollar per
ton of co2 or less and available right
now and this doesn't even count the huge
amount of concentrated solar and pv
solar and other technologies that are
likely to to come about now if that's
right it does suggest a very simple
policy prescription and that's to put on
a $25 per ton of carbon for the next 40
years and my view is that that would
lead plus all the R & D and D that needs
to be done basically it's it's the
second D of R & D and D we need
demonstration projects more than
anything right now because we have close
to market technologies that need to be
demonstrated but if you do those two
things my guess is that we'd see a
massive conversion of the power sector
especially in the rapidly growing
developing countries and if you have
done little experiment simple
experiments that if you allocate the
rights to a mission on an equal per
capita basis for example so that that
point three of world GNP is distributed
to be paid more by the rich countries
than the poor countries the US share of
that turns out to be or the u.s. cost
turns out to be about point seven of one
percent of u.s. GNP assuming a $25 per
ton carbon dioxide abatement cost to me
this is really the the essence of the
story how much is it going to cost to do
this we can't figure it out peering into
an economic model we have to do it by
thinking about how to promote a system
of technological change and we have to
talk to the engineers a lot more than we
do to understand what the existing
options are and what
marginal marginal costs are notice by
the way that all the things like wind
and other things which are also proven
in low cost a tanish can be factored in
to do some small part of it they're not
they're not the marginal solution they
are an infra marginal solution but they
add to this this low cost so for me the
bottom line is is the following I think
on a pretty robust set of parameters
where you realize that the technology is
not that expensive and not likely to be
that expensive you realize different
from Bob's point i would say that the
chances for major technological
improvements are enormous right now
because this is really a playground for
engineers if you ask me could they make
energy far more efficient I doubt it can
they make carbon less can they
decarbonize I'd say yes because that's a
new problem energy efficiency is an
ancient problem but decarbonisation is a
brand-new problem and so I think that
there are so many margins to work on
that the marginal cost of this are going
to be quite small my guess is that i'll
make one final prediction here last year
when i came here i said this was about
to be mainstream because i just thought
that the balance of constant benefits
are such that this will be the case i'll
i predict that by 2010 we have a post
kyoto international agreement that has a
global agreed target for mid-century on
co 2 ppm not co 2 EP p.m. but co 2 ppm
perhaps five hundred or so maybe
shouldn't be 554 mid-century it should
be aiming to stabilize below two times
pre-industrial carbon I think we're
actually going to get there my guess is
the next year every American
presidential candidate will have a very
strong climate change policy in in their
platform both sides of
of both parties what's happening at the
political level is that will enter into
post Kyoto negotiations in December of
this year at the conference of the
parties of the UN framework convention
on climate change in Bali in December
that'll open a debate that will last
through the US presidential elections
and through the Chinese Olympics
nothing's going to happen next year on
this and then in 2009 there'll be a new
president there will be post-olympic
cleanup and hangover and China and the
United States are going to agree on a
China and i should say US China and
India are going to agree three ways on
how to share the costs on doing this and
in 2010 the post Kyoto Protocol will be
signed takes two years to ratify it will
go into effect January 1 2013 thank you
very much
Jeff your optimism has been recorded so
okay so you are challenged to be back in
a few years time Nick you want to react
and I have very little to add on those
two I enjoyed them both very much just
one remark on what Scott said about the
importance of acting to support
developing countries in their
development including for example on
malaria I would I would be there and
I've been there and I agree entirely the
only remark I would make would be that
we know that whatever we do is bound to
leave poor countries when basically
because what will pull them out of
poverty is their own actions but there
are things that we can do to help and
however much we do it however much we do
deliver on the kinds of aid commitments
which I hope will in fact they be
delivered on they're still going to be
much poorer than we are over the next 30
40 50 years so we should act to reduce
those inequalities to support developing
countries in their plans for development
but it's going to lead the problem of
inequality still pretty severe so it
doesn't actually take it away but but
basically I didn't have any anything
more to add than that I just didn't
enjoy listening to them both and I I
loved Jeff's story at the end and i was
looking at sean Peters down in the front
row who led the team here and she's been
involved in glen eagles and
Kyoto and you NFC triple unit Triple C
negotiations the best part the last few
years and I couldn't quite interpret the
smile on her face as you were